Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today, Jeffrey Cain, senior fellow in Critical
Emerging Technologies at the Lincoln Policy
Network and also author of the book The Perfect
Police State An Undercover Odyssey into China's
Terrifying Surveillance Dystopia of the Future,
a book I recently read. Great to have
you on today. I really appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Thanks for having me, David.
Speaker 1: So I for people who maybe have
not studied this topic or have only a kind of
passing or a rudimentary understanding of what
has been going on in China, in particular
with the with the weaker population,
maybe we can back up a little and ask the
question what have relations been between the
Chinese Communist Party and the weaker population,
particularly in Xinjiang, historically in China?
Speaker 3: Yes, so so Xinjiang is a region of
China that's about twice the size of Texas,
and it's on, you can say, the western frontier
of what is today China. But historically it was
home to a group of people called the wiggers who
are mostly Muslim, and they populated this region
for hundreds almost a thousand years.
This is this is really their homeland.
I think a good comparison would be to imagine,
you know, the European settlers in America and
the Native Americans and that sort of how China
looks at this region. It's a place that it's been
expanding westward into and it keeps running
into this weaker population. And these other
ethnic minority groups who practice a different
religion have a distinct language, distinct
culture. There are about 12 million people
there, sparsely populated area. It's it's oasis
and desert and mountains, and it truly is the
place that China has been trying to build and
develop with oil and railroads and turning it into
this frontier land where Chinese settlers can can
go and they can find their riches of opportunity.
Speaker 1: So I mean, in terms of the motivations
for for the treatment of the weaker population
to be what it is. There are a variety of
perspectives that say this is mostly xenophobic
lines based on Muslim religion. There are
other perspectives that say there's a sort of
business-oriented perspective as you're talking
about and desires to turn that area into something
that is much more financially viable. What is the
origin of the circumstances as we now see them?
Speaker 3: So there's a lot of origins to the
situation in Xinjiang. There are currently about
1.8 million people in concentration camps in
this region, which is about one tenth of the
minority population. So imagine the, you know,
the North American equivalent. It's if a minority
blacks or Native Americans or whoever, it might be
one tenth of them being taken away without being
charged with a crime to a concentration camp.
The reasons for this many reasons, but it mostly
goes back to, you could say a war on terror, just
take it to an extreme. The US was waging the war
on terror for many years. It's calmed down now,
but China seized on that war on terror and took it
to an. Its authoritarian system over these people.
You know, the fact that they're protected areas,
ideas that they need to be purged, and so they
created this total surveillance dystopia using
artificial intelligence and over handed policing
and facial recognition cameras everywhere to
try to get inside the thoughts of every single
week or to predict their behavior and to try
to turn them into good patriots of the state.
Speaker 1: OK, so you mentioned the facial
recognition in the book. You talk about a
lot of the different sort of elements of the
surveillance state that are in place there,
kind of a two part question. Can you talk about
some of the other surveillance methods that that
are used and also are these only in place in
this region? Or are these also to some degree
in other parts of China as well?
Speaker 3: So when I was writing the book,
it was starting up, these measures were
being rolled out in the region and they were
experimental. About four years when I started
writing the book since I published it,
these methods, these tactics and technologies have
expanded throughout many parts of China. So Tibet,
great. Great example, Inner Mongolia.
There are all these regions of China
that are home to minorities that are who are being
repressed violently. So to give you an idea of
other tactics, just imagine an old sci fi novel or
a movie. I think that this is most like the movie
Minority Report with Tom Cruise about a police
force that tries to engage in predictive policing.
They can try to predict the murder and then arrest
the person and brainwash them. They they brainwash
them in the system before the murder can happen.
That's what's happening. It's just. I. Different
data points and the data points to
see things like whether a person
leaves the home front door at
seven a.m. every day, go to work,
whether they go grocery shopping every other
day at six p.m., What do they buy? There are
cameras watching them. What do they read? In
the case of my book, I said one young woman.
Doing too many books and there is a, you know,
there are these camera systems everywhere
that are watching you and gathering this data
and then trying to predict, are you going to
be a threat to the state in the future? Are you
going to try and commit some kind of terrorist
rebellious act against the Communist Party?
And so they take you to a concentration camp?
Psychologically, physically torture you and try
to get you to reinvent your supposed evil ways
and to become this the shell of your former
self where you simply accept and internalize
the demands of the Communist Party.
Speaker 1: Now, in the book,
you describe kind of two different layers.
There's the reeducation camps and what are
sometimes called the concentration camps, and the
concentration camps are worse than the reeducation
camps. It seems that typically there's more of an
exit path from the reeducation camps. If you sort
of comply and are, you know, doing what you're
asked. Can you talk about the relationship between
these two kind of levels that exists there?
Speaker 3: Certainly. So there are more
levels now. The system has expanded since I
wrote the book. So the lowest level is just
I mean, they call it a reeducation center of
the formal name is reeducation and training
center. And this is a place where you'll
be summoned there as a wig or a person
to undergo patriotic lessons to study law and
civics and all that sort of thing. And then after
you show you might go for like two years for a
class and you can go home every day, maybe at
six p.m. to see your family or maybe go home for
the weekends, but you have to stay there a certain
amount of time. And that's the that's one of the
lower levels. If you're deemed a more serious
threat, then you're kicked up to what is called a
detention center at a detention center is just a
euphemism for a full, fully loaded concentration
camp. That's where they have the guard dogs and
the SWAT teams and the the guard posts and snipers
up there. Watching every one of these places
are truly terrifying. I haven't been able to
personally visit one, and obviously it wouldn't be
something you can just drop in and report on
gather information on. But I was able to gather.
I interviewed more than a hundred leaguers who
had been through these camps, who had managed to
get out through various means and just the stories
they told were absolutely terrifying. I mean, this
is this is something different altogether from
the atrocities that we saw in the 20th century.
The 20th century was the age of genocide. It
was the age of the, you know, the big camps
where they had mass graves of Auschwitz, of the
Khmer Rouge in Cambodia. You know, the mass,
the mass killings of men, women and children. And
that was truly a terrifying time to be alive and
a lot of places. When it comes to Xinjiang and
China in, you know, in the twenty first century,
in the year twenty twenty two, now we're seeing
the evolution of new forms of mass surveillance
and mass atrocities. The Chinese nation. The
government has perfected ways of controlling
people or finding ways to control their identity,
to try to brainwash them into being someone else
without actually outright killing them. They don't
pull out a gun and shoot you and put you in a mass
grave. They don't have a gas chamber. They they
manage to erase your identity, erase your culture
and to essentially commit genocide through that
through the use of overhead and technology.
Speaker 1: So there is a movement that, oh man,
it's hard to even know how to do this justice and
bring it up. There are some who are increasingly
denying to different degrees that this is even
taking place. Now there are some who say it's
it's not a genocide. They don't necessarily deny
some elements of what you're saying, but you're
saying people aren't really being wholesale
killed. That part's not going on, although
what's going on isn't good. There's others
who are making claims like the messengers.
Presumably, some of the people you spoke to
are people who are making up these stories
to either attack the Chinese Communist Party
because they are anti anti-communist or whatever.
I don't want to read too narrowly characterized
where this comes from, but in the U.S., it does
seem to be folks who generally speaking, are more
sympathetic to not only the Chinese Communist
Party, but to the politics of the Hugo Chavez
Maduro type regimes in Venezuela. There seems
to be sort of like a in being in league there. I
can't adjudicate every single claim, but can
you talk a little bit about the origins of this
and whether there is any aspect of it that we
should be paying attention to specifically?
Speaker 3: Yes, so we know without any doubt
whatsoever by now that these atrocities
are happening, that the camps exist. We have
full documentation and we have satellite imagery.
We have thousands upon thousands of testimony
from refugees, many of which line up. In my case,
I interviewed one hundred and sixty eight
people, including not just refugees,
but people who were inside the system who actually
worked for the Chinese technology companies
building these systems. You know, I mean,
we went through a Chinese corporate records,
even Chinese companies that build these systems.
They like to brag. They're proud of what they do.
They don't see it as something shameful or worth
hiding. They've admitted to it openly in the
Chinese language. If you can read Mandarin, you
can find corporate reports that talk about what
they're doing and children. There isn't, you know,
there are no secrets anymore to what's going on.
And it's really unfortunate that in the states
in particular or just in the western world,
you know, there are people they tend to be more
on the left, on the hard left who, you know,
they think that you have to choose. The reasoning
goes that you have to choose one or the other
if you side with the United States of America,
that you are an imperialist colonialist bastard
who is just trying to oppress China, trying to
oppress global nonaligned, you know, people of
color movements that sort of how they frame it. So
therefore, the idea that you should be sympathetic
to China and see these these accusations of
genocide, these camps, therefore they must be made
up by this, you know, this American imperialist
system, these evil conservatives are just
making up stuff to smear China to justify a
war against China. You know, that's it's just,
you know, it's outright denialism. And it's
really unfortunate that some of the these these
sort of these leftists, these hard leftists and
socialists who claim to uphold progressive values
at home, they talk about social justice. And then
when it comes to minorities overseas and other
countries that are on the side of an authoritarian
regime. So the term tanky? And it just so I don't
know if you've heard that term thinking, but
Speaker 1: yeah, I've said before I fight
because it has such a pejorative connotation.
I tend to call it the revolutionary left,
and this is a someone on the left who considers
myself a progressive. I've chosen that term,
but certainly tank is a term I'm familiar with.
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah. And, you know, I would
consider myself kind of a progressive centrist. I
support human rights around the world. You know,
there are also people on the other side on the
right who, you know, just have these crazy,
crazy views about, you know, the Chinese
global conspiracy taking over the world.
So, you know, it's it's unfortunate that this
particular topic gets polarized when there are
major human rights atrocities happening.
Speaker 1: What about more specific? So
that's that gives us a great
kind of general orientation.
What about the more narrow claim that a lot
of what is being described as absolutely
happening? You can't deny the surveillance,
the satellite surveillance, all that, but
that there is not genocide taking place.
Speaker 3: So the genocide question is stepped in
and that falls under the international law of
genocide. So, so so here's the thing about the
genocide question. The one of the major problems
that needs to be one of the things that needs to
be established is the intent to commit genocide.
Chinese officials defend themselves by arguing
that they are not committing genocide. They are
simply developing the region there. They claim
that they're trying to lessen birthrates. They
don't want, you know, they want family planning.
And when they defend themselves that way, that
places these projects in a different kind of
framework. And that's what makes it more
difficult to prove that this is actually a
genocide that under international law, the one
major factor that would make this a genocide
that numerous academics and scholars have
documented well is the forced sterilization
of women and the forced sterilization in an
attempt to erase an entire people to a race.
The next generation. It's and that is really I
think that if there is going to be that one kind
of that one turning point within international
law, that one thing that's going to be the thing
that will define this as genocide in the future.
Speaker 1: The book is the perfect police state.
We've been speaking with the author, Jeffrey
Caine. I so appreciate your time today and really
recommend the book to anybody who's interested
in this topic or isn't yet interested.
But but really should be really.
Appreciate your time. Thanks, David.